this is a production of Cornell
University
fabulous so today I'll be talking about
my work the past couple of years that
have been here in establishing breeding
priorities and developing cultivars for
organic vegetable growers here in the
Northeast organic growers as I'm sure
you all know face unique challenges to
their production because of the organic
standard which was put in place in 2002
there are limitations on the sorts of
materials that organically certified
growers can use in their production so
there are a couple of major differences
between organic and conventional growers
one is the issue of soil fertility
without synthetic fertilizers organic
farms are often quite nitrogen limited
though organic growers you have ways of
managing their soil fertility increasing
the nitrogen through the application of
animal manure and nitrogenous cover
crops it's still often the case that
there's less nitrogen available for
their plants and organic growers like
conventional growers face major disease
and pest pressures but unlike
conventional growers where there are
quite effective chemically based
management tools organic growers often
lack effective approved materials to
manage these these challenges and so
they're more often reliant on genetic
resistance to these these challenges
than conventional growers weed
management is also a big issue in
organic production and organic growers
also need to use organically certified
seed so so the organic farm is different
from a conventional farm but there's a
question of doing needs to be breeding
for organic management aren't we already
breeding for Disease resistant and
nutrient use efficient plants we are but
but when it comes to organic farms
organic production there's a difference
of priorities so with disease resistance
for example there are diseases that are
well-managed under conventional
production systems common buntz in wheat
for example has been very effectively
managed through the use of seed
treatments which are not approved
materials for organic growers and so
that's an instance where disease
resistant where genetic resistance would
be more important a higher priority for
organic growers so for organic
production to be particularly successful
growers need varieties that excel under
organic conditions which means that we
need to be trialing varieties under
organics management if they're meant for
organic growers or develop varieties
that are intended specifically for
organics so how do we develop those
varieties well one of the ways that I've
been thinking about it is a matter of
adaptability and stability under
different environments so this graph
from Finley and Wilkinson shows shows a
trial of barley varieties under
different environments and the x-axis
shows the mean yield of all of the
varieties in seven different
environments and then every variety
their yield in those environments is
plotted so so the average yield of all
the varieties is the dashed line here
with a slope of one and varieties that
that these authors label as well-adapted
or generally adapted are those that do
well under all environments do better
than average under all environment so
variety a in this instance variety B is
an example of a poorly adapted variety
it does worse than the average across
environments variety C
is a variety with low stability so it
does particularly poorly in low yielding
environments but well when it's when
it's in a good a good field generally
and the particularly interesting for for
my purposes is variety D here which is a
variety with high stability so it does
well it does pretty well under low and
are low yielding environments but it
does it does the same generally across
those environments so the authors of
this paper conclude that selecting for
for high yielding varieties under high
yielding conditions if you don't know
how those varieties do under low
yielding conditions can result in
varieties that don't particularly do
well under those yields low yielding
environments which we can think of as
being representative perhaps of organics
management conditions so four varieties
that do well under good conditions those
might not be appropriate for organic
growers and dr. Kevin Murphy
demonstrated this again in a study that
was done in 2007 with wheat varieties
where they under in five different
environments looked at the yield of
these varieties under conventional and
organic management and then ranked them
according to yield and showed showed
that the yield rank changed quite
drastically between conventional and
organic conditions suggesting that if
this was in a breeding program selecting
for the lines that did well under
conventional management would not have
resulted in in lines that were that good
for organic so those that did the best
under organic management were the ones
that would have been chosen under
conventional systems so there there are
some traits that are generally important
to organic growers those that are
dictated by the standards and then there
are traits that are region or market
specific which also need to be
considered when we supply
we're looking to support a particular
community of growers so in this instance
some of the work that I've done has been
particularly to the Northeast and
organic growers here I spoke last year
about a report that we were writing that
that summed up results of a survey that
we did asking growers vegetable growers
here in the Northeast who were using
organic practices what was most
important to them and what the traits
were that they would like to suggest be
worked on to support their production
and so part of the reports that we put
out last August was a prioritization of
many specific crop specific trait needs
for organic growers and the top five
sets are listed here so those that are
under bullet point three were all deemed
to be as important more important than
four in size but not as important as one
and two and you can see here that
there's a mix of traits that are
specific to the climate and culture of
the Northeast I'll say about that so
things like stress tolerance for
broccoli heat tolerance for Rig Allah
resistance to diseases in high tunnels
which are increasing in prevalence we
here for organic growers in the
Northeast and then also traits that are
important for consumer demands like the
color and quality of lettuce so we need
to take the varieties that do well for
the growers that have the qualities that
they're looking for like flavor this is
a graph showing that growers rate flavor
as being a really important quality in
breeding efforts so we need to take
varieties that already do well in the
markets for these growers and improve
the traits that will help those
varieties excel under northeast organic
conditions the reports that we put out
last year we put up on ecommons and I'm
hopeful that it'll be a useful tool for
anyone who is interested in working on
developing organic varieties whether
that's evidence
like Cornell or at seed companies across
the region so I'll talk very briefly
about two efforts that I've been working
on in developing varieties for growers
here in the Northeast but generally
across the northern us under the
northern organic vegetable improvement
collaborative so one is disease
resistant high-quality delicata squash
and the other is an early blocky bell
pepper so these are one of the one of
the the survey results we asked folks to
rate the importance of different
diseases as pre as breeding priorities
one of the one of the questions we asked
was about powdery mildew most of the
people who responded to the question
said yes this is a big problem for for
us and cucurbit production this is
something that we would like people to
focus on so i sorry so my so the
Delicato works that i've been doing i've
have been looking at powdery mildew
resistance and Cornell Bush delicata in
the far right bottom corner is the
source of powdery mildew resistance that
I used I a couple of summers ago crossed
it with a couple of commercial
commercial lines with higher quality
these three boxes here which have as you
can see from last year quite a lot
higher severity of powdery mildew and
the breeding lines that I've been
working on I was able to fix the powdery
mildew resistance using a capsule marker
that was developed in our lab and all of
those show very low powdery mildew
severity in the field which is
encouraging I also have been looking at
screening the material for bricks as a
an assay for quality and then the second
breeding project that I've been working
on is an early blocky bell pepper and
growers here in the Northeast or gay
vegetable growers often grow this
variety which is called ace and folks
have said that they they like the
variety it produces quite a lot of food
it produces the chair food earlier than
other varieties that they've grown but
it could use some changes in the fruit
shape I've heard several people
independently tell me that they think it
looks really ugly which maybe shouldn't
matter but apparently it does so so I've
been working on that and I crossed ace
to a blockier bell pepper called
Aristotle these were both hybrids and
last year I grew f2 families which
sounds weird to say and looked for early
earliness in these these lines so the
parents are ace and Aristotle and this
is showing the percent of the plot that
was flowering on July 6th so ace had
already passed the 50% point and
Aristotle was still not really flowering
identified four lines that were almost
as early as ace if not earlier and then
looked for blocky fruit and have
identified two promising lines that will
be trailing along with the delicata here
in free ville and on some organic farms
here in the Northeast so in New York as
well as at our partner institutions in
Wisconsin Oregon and Washington through
Novick which I'm pretty excited about so
with that I would like to thank
everybody who has been helpful and there
are many people and our funding source
of the USDA nifA with that I will maybe
take a question if which I says I can
[Applause]
yeah turn if you had your survey you had
organic growers that were certified and
non-certified there any difference
between those groups in there in there
there weren't really many there there
weren't any real differences between the
two we broke them up in we asked them to
self-identify whether they were
certified or not certified by the
non-certified were all growers who were
following NOP practices or who were
natural naturally certified not
certified but naturally labeled so they
were using practices that were quite
similar we were curious to see if if
those groups had different thoughts but
but they all sort of seemed to have the
same things to say the genetics of the
Blackie shape I don't remember the names
of the genes that have been that have
been identified for fruit shape but I
know that there aren't many of them
controlling fruit shape that's a great
question that I'll be sure to read up
more closely on before Mike name thanks
mark
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu